hey everybody we are here once again for
a donald
trump coronavirus press conference will
he come clean about coronavirus will he
admit that things are completely out of
control will he concede
that he didn't handle it the way he
should have could have
handled it or will we hear continued
lies
from the president scheduled for the top
of the hour
i have a guess we'll see which side of
that guess
i end up on momentarily i do have my new
microphone as many of you can see we're
still working out the kinks with it but
some significant improvements made today
and these are you know we're working
with a bunch of elements of audio here
and getting them all to work together
properly is important and
this is this is so funny you might find
this funny you guys remember this
furious trumpet
jimmy from philly who calls in he always
has some issue
he is you know a trump guy he's against
bernie he's all about
you know no handouts everybody
figure things out for themselves he
asked for me to send him my old mic
for free he's like just send me the 500
mic david you don't need it anymore do
you take a listen to this
david jimmy from philly i hear you're
getting a new microphone
uh how about let me have the old one
right
i'll pay shipping let can you imagine if
i'm going to say hey you know what
i'm going to give my microphone away to
somebody how about the guy who i have to
hang up on because he's so disgustingly
homophobic during phone calls let me
send
him the mic no jimmy you're not getting
the mic
you can go and buy one for 500 if that's
what you want
uh i just just i mean it's it's
legendary in a sense
but it's also so incredibly pathetic um
plus the old mic becomes now part of my
mobile setup and now i've got a better
microphone for my mobile setup but you
know i still have a use for it
but no jimmy is not getting the
microphone um
jake says i think i saw you trying not
to laugh at the trump diapers fill em
ups
um i don't i didn't see i don't know
what that is but yesterday when trump
said fuji film a number of times it was
really weird
thanks to dirk peters for the super chat
matty ice pvd says david if trump wins
reelection will a significant percentage
of the population emigrate thoughts on
being an expat mike sounds great
no you know interestingly on on the
friday show i'm i'm going to address the
question what would it take for me to
leave the united states permanently
and for the most part this is something
people say if x wins if y doesn't win
i'm leaving the country first of all
it's actually hard to leave the country
in most cases and
it's not hard to leave it's hard to
legally stay somewhere else indefinitely
i have some options but uh i actually
plan to talk about that
on friday a neutral music is asking
about barr's testimony today yeah i have
a couple of clips we could look at it
just while we're waiting here
here is uh congresswoman jayapal
going after william barr let's take a
listen because
confederate flags and one even with a
dark-haired doll with a noose
around its neck are you aware that these
protesters called for the governor
to be lynched shot and beheaded
no you're not aware of that i was not
aware major protests
in michigan you're the attorney general
and you didn't know
that the protesters called for the
governor to be lynched
shot and beheaded so obviously you
couldn't be concerned about that
well there are a lot of protests around
the united states and
uh on june
in certain parts of the country you're
very aware of those
but when protesters with guns and
swastikas i'm very
i am aware of excuse me mr martin that's
my
time and i control it you are aware of
certain kinds of protesters but in
michigan
when protesters carry guns and
confederate flags
and swastikas and call for the governor
of michigan to be beheaded and shot
and lynched somehow you're not aware of
that
somehow you didn't know about it so you
didn't send federal agents in
to do to the president's supporters what
you did
to the president's protesters in fact
you didn't you didn't put pepper balls
on those protesters
so the point i'm trying to make here mr
barr that i think is very important for
the country to understand
is that there is a real discrepancy in
how
you react as the attorney general the
top cop in this country
when white men with swastikas storm a
government building
with guns there is no need for the
president to quote
activate you because they're getting the
president's personal agenda done
but when black people and people of
color
protest police brutality systemic racism
and the president's very own lack of
response to those critical issues
then you forcibly remove them with armed
federal officers pepper bombs because
they
are considered terrorists by the
president
you take an aggressive approach to black
lives matter protests
but not to right wing extremists
threatening to lynch a governor
if it's for the trumps if it's for the
president's benefit don't get it right
mr barr i have responsibility for the
federal
government and the white house is the
seat of the mr barlow
anyway so you get a sense of how it was
going by the way demon
sperm is trending on twitter that's
really weird um
but so it was really a complete and
total mess um
here's another point barr saying i guess
saying to david cicilline oh who i've
met before
that it's okay to use tear gas on
peaceful protesters in some cases
ever appropriate mr barr for officers to
use force against peaceful protesters
yes or no
not against peaceful protest so you also
don't mention in your statement today or
your testimony that federal officers
have even tear-gassed elected
representatives
county commissioner sharon myron
confirmed firsthand
last night i was tear gassed by a
federal occupying force
i saw throw canisters of poison without
warning into a non-violent crowd
including elders and then vulnerable
yeah and on july 23 the mayor ted
wheeler was tear gassed
he called the tactics of the officers
abhorrent
these are elected representatives with
grave concerns that officers are using
abhorrent tactics
including tear-gassing elderly
non-violent americans
so let me ask you sir do you think it's
ever appropriate
to use tear gas on peaceful protesters
yes or no
well the problem in these things
sometimes occur because
uh it's hard to separate people mr barr
my question is very specific
do you think it is ever appropriate to
use tear gas on
peaceful protesters it is yes or no it
is
it is appropriate to use tear gas when
it's indicated
uh to disperse on peaceful process first
and unlawful assembly and sometimes
unfortunately
peaceful protesters are affected by okay
so this reminds me of um
let me see if i can actually find well
maybe we'll do that later i actually
have an interesting
an interesting clip i could play for you
of john u sort of like
the beginning of this type of of
response in these situations let's see
if we have any updates on the news
conference not quite yet
i also did want to play just a little
bit joe biden actually took questions
from the press today
which i think is great why not let's
take a listen to a little bit of it
you alluded to this in in your remarks
and i bring it up because
polling is bearing this out a little bit
but are you running
against president trump or for
president and for joe biden in other
words you alluded to this
but a lot of voters seem to think or
saying that their support hinges on the
fact that you're not the president
so why perhaps should they be voting for
you and not just
against the president that's why i'm
laying out these detailed plans
look uh
i'm running because trump is the
president
and i think our democracies at stake for
real
and uh what seems to be the case
is many americans those who don't like
me and those who do
view me as the antithesis of trump
and i believe that i am
and i when i announced
i said i was running because i thought
it was essential
to restore basic decency the soul of
america
but i really meant it it wasn't you know
remember i got criticized early on for
saying that
now everybody's talking about the seoul
america decency honor respect
the second reason i said i was running
is because
even back when people were talking about
how well the economy was moving
i thought the middle class was still
getting crushed
and working class folks were hurting
badly
all this talk about how happy they were
i didn't i mean listen
am i finding myself uh incredibly
inspired by
what he's saying no but is it obviously
better than the lunacy
of re-electing donald trump yeah
obviously so it's a pretty pretty
crystal clear
uh path forward as far as i'm concerned
there welcome to everybody watching on
twitch by the way i want to say thank
you to
i burn easy for subscribing
at tier one on twitch where we surpassed
40 000 followers yesterday during my
stream with
chess master uh levy brosman
surpassed 40 000 followers uh
and you know what's insane on youtube
we're only 200 subscribers from 900
000. it may actually happen uh during
this stream that's in
let me see if i can see if i can pull up
do we have any kind of live counter
there because we may actually get to
over 900 000 during this stream let's
see here oh it only updates by
thousand now on social blade that's
interesting but look at that
we are we are dangerously close to
seeing that roll over
um and then the race to a million is on
so this this may actually happen during
the stream which would be wild
um this the the social blade only
updates every thousand
but we're actually only 259 away
we're at eight nine nine seven four one
so that would be exciting maybe that
will roll over
uh while we are here today and then one
million will be on the horizon which is
an amazing thing
okay let me look at some of these super
chats that are coming in because people
are asking questions
uh walker anderson says is it
responsible to suggest a government case
cover-up based upon circumstantial
evidence i don't even know what walker's
talking about
andreas peterson says so sweden is kind
of chill now david how about that beer
and political discussion
i'm not going to sweden anytime soon my
friend zachary foster says david do you
think people
like peter hotes saying even with a
vaccine
social distancing and masks everywhere
from now on is realistic seems cynical i
don't know who that is
um listen the day the vaccine comes out
things don't go back to normal but i
believe eventually things will get back
to normal
kimmy head says hi dave have you ever
granted a make-a-wish to a sickly
superfan if not would you honor such a
request would you give a tour of your
studio
um i think probably that's more
appropriate for contacting me offline
but we've not done anything with with
make-a-wish uh to date
we do have a hype train that just
started over on twitch which is exciting
our record remains at 620 percent
matthias germany says hey david what is
so funny about trump's plasma well it's
funny that trump still can't get it
right
he's off and on trump keeps calling it
convalescent plasma
the word is plasma and he gets visibly
confused
every time that it's on the piece of
paper he's reading and he just can't
seem to get it right
consistently um and it's sort of like
fuji films it's it's just
very weird waffles giraffes says will it
take weeks to declare the election
winner i don't believe it will
i don't believe it will we are already
at level two of a hype train on twitch
i also want to say thanks to christopher
mccaslin
who's new member number one today at
joinpakman.com
and elizabeth vargas is number two
at joinpakman.com as we stand by waiting
for president donald trump
will he come clean about coronavirus
today probably not
probably not would be my expectation
neutral music asks how do you suggest
defending against the growing
q anon pizzagate misinformation that
seems to be growing i have friends who
believe this [ __ ]
honestly i don't know the is it i don't
know if we should be ignoring it i
certainly don't think
you know detailed debunkings are the way
to go um
so i don't i don't really know the
answer there but it's a real problem and
uh
you know we'll see we'll see uh how much
it uh grows if at all as we get closer
to november
danny thompson asks do you feel it's a
good idea to do a show now on how to
register to vote with usa.gov so
everyone is ready to vote in 39 states
you can register to vote online
and check to ensure you are registered
yeah i mean i think that what i should
do is because i'm so regularly talking
about
voting i should just continue to mention
um usa.gov i think that that does make a
lot of sense
the beckminator says hey david polls
show biden going up in texas
i call it dejas if he does win texas
house screwed are republicans not just
for this year but potentially for years
to come
very screwed i wouldn't expect it and to
be perfectly frank trump doesn't even
biden doesn't even come close to needing
texas to win
uh and if if biden just wins florida it
becomes extraordinarily difficult for
trump to
get re-elected but i think putting
republicans in a position to have to
spend money in texas is still a good
thing any dollar they have to spend in
texas to be sure that trump gets it
is a dollar that they can't spend
somewhere else
looks like we are about to get um some
live
video here still sitting at 899 000
youtube subscribers at least for the
time being
uh we are live in the room as i like to
say and standing by for donald trump's
press
briefing ali way says have you seen dr
jeff hester's graph showing case numbers
changing abruptly on the day hospitals
were told to give data to hhs instead of
cdc
occurring along partisan lines yes
indeed and in fact
i have a video out an hour ago
is the trump administration faking
coronavirus numbers and i
quote jeff and i encourage you to check
out that clip
um james montalbano says
today's show sponsored by fujifilm
absolutely the dark half says it's
almost
over nine hundred thousand breaks
glasses yeah i mean
this is really a big accomplishment for
us at some point today
we are going to surpass uh we are going
to get to 900
000 youtube subscribers we're currently
233 away 233 away
there's 4 300 people watching on youtube
we could hit this right now
if people were so inclined um what by
so tomorrow i'm going to talk about the
path to 1 million which of course would
just be
absolutely huge huge huge for us uh but
yeah we
unless something goes very wrong we
could be just minutes but but
at most hours from getting to 900
000 youtube subscribers a big deal and
uh we're over um uh 40 000 on twitch as
well which is important
we do have a level two hype train going
at 51
we've got about a minute left in order
to do that over on twitch
and that would be great uh we are at
level two
right now level two is not bad level
five is obviously best
matt oh oh hold on a second hold on a
second before we go any further
um i want to show you
where is this somebody sent me david
pakman bingo
and this is like this is really good um
this is the david pakman bingo card and
i think that it's not perfect but it
actually has a bunch of pretty funny
stuff on it so this would be not like
what we pl
this isn't trump bingo this is david
pakman bingo so
i play hatred mail okay that's fine i
say from the standpoint of
that's great exactly as we predicted on
this show days ago
yeah and but there's an addition to that
and which and then i go
not to pat myself on the back many
people were predicting it so like for
example i might say
exactly as we predicted on this show
days ago it appears that the trump
administration is now lying about case
numbers
not that i was the only one predicting
it i'm not patting myself on the back i
was just pointing out something so
obvious
so that's the the sort of format of that
one caller drops call
frequent occurrence on the david pakman
show clickbaity youtube video title
daily i mean that's that that should
almost be the center square
we have a voicemail this one i feel is
kind of cheap because
we play a voicemail every day maybe i'll
zoom it in
mentions going to a cafe or a coffee
shop that's a nice bingo square i like
that
i tell a story about a current or
previous producer yeah there was a good
one
last week about vegan pat eating a sour
cream based sauce during a team dinner
which was a great story
i mentioned an opinion that is unpopular
with progressives or a spouse an opinion
unpopular with progressives
love it we've got a great bonus show for
you today that's every day so that's
accurate
i call something weaponized or i refer
to a membership discount that's absurd i
would add
absurd or borderline illegal membership
discount
jimmy from philly is the center square
on this one
runs fingers through hair yeah sometimes
i'll end up with like a piece of hair
like that and so i will see it on my
various monitors and i'll pull it out of
my hair
i want to know what you think often i
end segments that way
elements of blank i use that today
caller asks is that me and i say yes it
is
can you imagine that's a common one it's
crazy what's going on that's true
caller sounds as if underwater i do a
hard
sell membership pitch you know i don't
really do hard sell membership pitch
i usually do listen i'm doing the show
for everybody no matter what
if you can contribute i would love it i
don't know that that's really a hard
sell
i describe either myself or a caller as
being shot out of a cannon that that's
beautiful
maga nanny as a reference to kaylee
mckennany
i run down my personal stock holdings
and yeah and then let me say thank you
too so the podcast
only if you watch the podcast are you
familiar with let me say thank you to
because i do try to thank a couple of
supporters
every single oh well actually no i do it
on the live streams that's right so that
that actually makes sense
so every time we do a bingo board here's
what i ask for
suggest let's iterate okay
contact me by email and tell me what's a
square
that could be replaced with something
better so like what's the least
good thing here i think hatred mail is a
weak square
because it's like okay we we play hatred
mail it's not a great square
it's scheduled david you could replace
hatred mail with x
okay like for example as people are
suggesting i refer to stephen kenneth
destiny bonnell ii
or hassan destiny [ __ ] the second that
would be a funny square i think
maybe um you know i don't know
we have a voicemail isn't good because
we have a voicemail every day let me
know what i should be replacing these
with but don't do it in chat oh talking
about my garden is good
email me through the website contact
form because it's just hard to keep up
with all of the suggestions in chat
but that's a great starting bingo board
referring to chess might be interesting
or a chess analogy that's not bad
um there's a lot of good ideas you i
mean you guys are much better at this
than i am that's for sure
so let me know um
joshua jenkins is coming in out of
nowhere with a hundred dollar super chat
and says
we should shame people who use the
police as their personal protection
force people are buying guns left and
right and don't think that homicides are
out of the question during a pandemic
joshua i don't i'm going to be perfectly
clear with you with peace and love
i don't totally know what you're saying
but i
so appreciate the support i really
really do
um other super chats
matt chavez have you looked at stella
emmanuel
and trump retweeting her video promoting
hydroxy and it being removed is she
whack or do we need to look at it again
um okay i'm going to talk about that
tomorrow so i don't want to dig in
too deep as far as that goes let me say
thank you to jennifer marshall thomas
moleman
matt johansen and daniel corpus new
members
3 4 5 and 6 today
and let me take this as an opportunity
to do a very
soft cell this is a soft cell that's a
band right
didn't soft cell sing tainted love
am i missing that saw did i just come
across a 80s man name soft cell
or was that something else now i'm not
even sure
soft sell i think that's the name of
that band
anyway let me give you a soft sell um
our program is mostly funded by members
and so i would really love it if you
went to my website joinedpakman.com and
got a membership it's really really
cheap
the the normal prices are really cheap
we estimate only about
half of one percent of our audience has
a membership
uh if we could go to one percent we
would be golden if we could go to two
percent we would be platinum
if we could go to three percent we would
go to
pac-manium pac-manium beautiful
um the soup the coupon 2020 now saves
you 66
you don't have to use it but you can if
you do use it you'll only pay a dollar
eighty something a month if you pay for
the entire year at once
and i will thank folks who sign up um
basically the way i think about it is if
you sign up because a couple bucks a
month is reasonable for your budget
you're subsidizing the show for more
than 100 other people arguably for 200
other people at 0.5
support you sign up you're covering
200 people getting the david pakman show
and the streams
and the bingo and the you know zucchinis
and all of this stuff
so um consider it consider it is all i'm
saying and it is a
very very uh soft sell that i am giving
you today
extremely tainted tainted love as we say
um wayne kerr says how would you counter
family members living overseas that are
getting brainwashed by fox news their
opinion is the riots are the biggest us
issue
why are family members overseas so tuned
in to fox news i would start there
knowledgeable king judah says chief
wiggum bar
perjury bar francisco resto says will
you make a prediction on viden's bp
pick at some point i mean it would it's
like coming in three days
uh i think it'll be warren kamala harris
or susan rice i don't i don't know which
i don't have any
special insight although it feels like
and you know facts don't care about
certainly my feelings it feels like
it's been moving a little bit in the
direction of elizabeth warren i don't
know why it feels that way
and it i may be completely wrong thanks
to silent knight
and nato jenkins who between the two of
them have just gifted
10 subscriptions on twitch unbelievable
an incredible number also titan mars
productions
and jatraplasts as well as spicy
corduroy
have subscribed over on twitch which is
just incredible i mean
really really incredible um
do people want to see the john u clip i
was talking about
i don't want to get cut off by trump but
let me see if i can find it
john u conyers let me see if i can find
this
this is like an amazing amazing clip
but i'm having trouble finding it
uh where is it oh here it is okay
so this is what i'm reminded of i'll
turn the volume up here so that we'll
hear it and we'll turn it up nice and
loud with volume master just so we don't
miss it
here is uh oh by let me see how let's
check in on where we are
on subscriptions we're only 170
subscriptions from 900 000 on youtube
there's 5 500 people watching right now
if just 200 of you
hit that subscribe button we would see
this roll over
in real time but here's the clip i'm
going to play for you john you was a
lawyer for george w bush
and he epitomizes the
not answering a question during these
congressional hearings okay i'm going to
load this up and take a listen to this
thank you is there anything
missed professor you that the president
could not order to be done to a suspect
if he believed it necessary for national
defense
well mr chairman i think that goes back
to the
quote you just read because no i'm just
asking you the question maybe it does
doesn't but what do you think i think
it's the same question that i was asked
well what's the answer first can i can i
make clear i'm not talking about
and you don't have to make anything
clear just answer the question
council i just want to make sure i'm not
saying anything you don't have to worry
about not saying just
answer the question this is like really
really good i've used this actually in
classes i've taught
question okay my my thinking right now
yes right now okay my thinking right now
this moment
yes this moment mr chairman is that
uh you know first
the question you're posing what is the
answer
you're wasting my time look council
practice
could the president order a suspect
buried alive mr chairman
i don't think that i have ever i'm
asking you that given the advice that
the president could
bury somebody alive i've never given
that advice
wasn't the question i didn't ask you if
you ever gave him advice
i asked you do you think the president
could order a suspect buried alive mr
chairman
my view right now is that i don't think
a president would
no american president would ever have to
order that or feel it no but so
it's not still no president would ever
have to do that necessary to order that
i i i i think we understand the games
that are being played
okay now let me turn to uh so that is
just the prototypical example
of what you know we see from william
barr john you
does it in a different way but i mean
that it is just
cr that's nuts right i mean is that am i
i feel like even as desensitized as i am
to some of this bs like that's crazy
that video is insane what we just saw
and when i show that to students when
i've taught classes
they everybody gets a kick out of it i
mean people really seem to understand
and then you identify that
done sometimes more skillfully by other
people but it's essentially the exact
same thing
with the different i mean yeah bar was
interrupting more i think is certainly
uh certainly fair to say
thanks to amakur paul the bum
and ireman for supporting via twitch
um we are at this point
of standing by for donald trump's
schedules for 15 minutes ago
to brief us on coronavirus uh super
chats
continue to come in remember if you're
just joining us on youtube make sure to
hit that like
and the subscribe button we are just
about 140 subscribers away
from 900 000 an incredible milestone 140
subscribers
from 000 a number we're monitoring
very closely yaya kelly says keep up the
great work
thanks yaya miguel robles says look why
look up why demon sperm is trending it's
worth it i'll look it up later just in
case it's not um
appropriate donna williams says do you
think about vaccine will help trump get
reelected i think that
if if there is widespread availability
of a vaccine that trump can credibly
take credit for
it probably helps him a few points i
don't know that it gets him re-elected
alvaro s says are you ever going to
start covering biden's news conferences
he just had one today
uh i i yes i would like to i'm trying to
the scheduling is not always ideal
but i am certainly trying to i see a lot
of people on twitch asking me to enable
bt
tv emotes i'm glad to do that but i need
someone to email me how to do it i just
i don't really know
people ask for it i honestly don't know
what it is if you can email me through
my website
i will certainly look at doing that a
few other thank yous coming in
christina marie wentworth is new member
number seven today on my website
chad thomas is new member number eight
he's a giga chad from what i'm seeing
trevor weber trevor weber i like that is
new member number nine
rohit rahm manoar is new member number
10
jack turner is new member number 11.
don mooney is new member number 12
mark giles or giles is new member number
13
elver gonzalez number 14 coming in
strong
and damon ford is new member number 15
today i really appreciate your support
also thanks to
hensho jutsu for subscribing with
prime over on twitch
let's look at a few other super chats
zachary foster says david i think my
question is more along the lines of
how do we clearly communicate a return
to normal
without calling it new normal the world
has seen way worse and returned to
societal norms
it it's it's going to happen zachary so
eventually we will have more effective
treatments the vaccines will start to
roll out
we may only by the way where is this
background audio coming from i guess
it's coming from here
i'll turn that down a little um the
vaccine will
will the vaccines will become more
effective over time
and eventually we will get back to not
needing to wear masks and travel will
resume but it could take a couple of
years that's the reality so for me it's
less about new normal
it's more about what's reasonable right
now what makes sense right now given the
situation on the ground
and of course it's very different um
depending on your sort of tolerance
for accepting science or following
donald trump blindly
sadly james montalbano says missing from
the bingo
board x and what i mean by that is yeah
i use that frequently um
i already did joshua jenkins anita
blackhawk
beautiful mr pakman any chance you put
your workout routine on instagram tv
no i am envious of your life sh sinewy
body
and would love to follow your slim
nastics yeah i just don't think so
sam says hey david what do you think
about d platforming and censoring
sencoring people that actively try to
mislead and misinform
conspiracy nuts anti-vaccine listen
let's focus on education
and if we had an educated public that
crap would never even get the time of
day
i think that that's a better way than
debating censorship
alexander verdun says did you hear about
the geopolitical conflict between
chile and argentina over the issue of
cape horn i did not
nasty questions says watching barr's
hearing today was maddening thanks for
streaming
hi from powerfully infected texas sorry
to hear that
unknown prodigy with some chess advice
says castle early
never forget um none
pizza be left none none pizza beef left
okay has subscribed with twitch prime
and
kadara77 has subscribed
with twitch prime which is great to see
i see dead llamas says hey david a good
thing to keep an eye on
is sturgis south dakota the yearly biker
rally is set to happen and it's one of
the biggest in the world
mostly trump supporters set to happen
friday the
7th of august okay jeff archer has
signed up at the soyboy level evan
fields
says just sending good vibes david
thanks for all you do thank you evan
sean mccracken says have you looked at
the contribution of the fed
quantitative easing corporate bailout
programs
to the social strife we find ourselves
in inflation etc
i have not a shinigami
has subscribed on youtube mr lieutenant
pink says
pacmanium yes the rarest of rare earth
elements for lack of a better term
jonathan hawkins has bingo square idea
when you use the long
u oh like tulsi instead of tulsi or
tulsa instead of tulsa
um someone pointed out that i use a
liquid u
when pronouncing the word new as opposed
to nu
but isn't that how it's pronounced like
the word n-e-w
isn't it pronounced new who pronounces
it like as if it were n-o-o
that sounds weird new i got a new car
come on come on new
exactly exactly osborne says anybody but
warren i will not vote for joe biden if
he picks elizabeth
okay i hope you vote in a state where it
doesn't matter
sam batalieri has subscribed on youtube
at the beta level
hkn says keep up the great work david
tristan mccoppen says do you think that
we can get real coronavirus data somehow
if so how
worried i'm in a red state i don't have
the answer at this point
i don't have the answer i wish i did let
me say thanks to gene rogers who just
made a pledge at patreon.com
david pakman we're going to count that
as member number 16 which makes jason
keenan member number 17 and
i believe i missed someone earlier hold
on marcus carney is new member number
18.
stefan staff or stefan staff
is new member number 19. uh i think that
gets me caught up that's everybody right
jason keenan i just mentioned
uh okay very good i am caught up there
from the standpoint of memberships at
joinedpakman.com
the most beautiful way to support the
david pakman show
um oh what's going on with me let's see
we're still holding steady at 8.99 yeah
if you're just joining us
we are only a we're now down to 100. we
are 100
youtube subscribers away from rolling
over to 900
000 which would be amazing to do live if
it doesn't happen live it'll happen
within a couple of hours just the way
things have been going
but 6 700 of you are watching on youtube
right now a hundred of you must not yet
be subscribed
let's do it right now hit that subscribe
button and let's make it happen
uh down to 99.99 more
and we can do it wouldn't this be
amazing people are confused it looks
like we're a thousand away
youtube now only updates subscriber
counts
every thousand so we're actually only
97 away on my phone it tells me the
actual number
we're only 97 away um
so that would i mean that would just be
wild it would be great to do it
i'll keep an eye on it maybe i'll just
oh oh boy we might miss it because
t-rump is coming out the mango menace
the tangerine terror let's take a listen
thank you very much
today my administration has taken a
momentous step toward
achieving american pharmaceutical
independence
very very big big step
a focus of our campaign to bring
america's critical
supply chains and medical manufacturing
back to the usa we've been working on
this for a long time
this is a core of our strategy to
protect our people from
the horrible china virus people should
it never happened should have never been
here
they should have stopped it in the
decades before i took office foreign
nations were allowed to freely plunder
our factories and loot our industries
take our business out of the united
states
industry millions of jobs were
vacuumed out just taken out so easily
sucked out
our politicians let that happen and
our communities were stripped and
shipped in many cases to china and all
over the world countries all over the
world
nearly four years ago we launched a bold
effort to revitalize american
manufacturing enact
fair trade deals and bring our
industries back home where they belong
how'd that work when the china virus
landed on our shores it became clearer
than
ever before that restoring american
manufacturing
is a core matter of national security
we must never be reliant on a foreign
nation for america's
medical or other needs and that includes
many other needs
i just want to say that pfizer just
announced
a little while ago that they're
combining phase two
and phase three trials
and the vaccine looks like it's really
heading in a very rapid direction in a
very positive direction
first time that's happened and there are
many months ahead of any other
trial there's never been anything like
it so it's the fastest ever and
to me it's very exciting today i'm proud
to announce
one of the most important deals in the
history of u.s pharmaceutical
industries my administration has reached
a historic agreement
with a great american company you
remember this company it's called
from the good old camera age the old
days say it
to begin producing critical
pharmaceutical ingredients it's called
kodak
oh okay and it's going to be right here
in america so i want to congratulate the
people in kodak they've been
working very hard members of my
administration are
present in rochester right now rochester
new york good place
and they're trying to finalize this
groundbreaking deal and they will be
announcing this deal i want to thank
governor andrew cuomo and his
representatives we've worked really well
together on this deal it's a big deal
it's got a great deal and a great deal
for new york and a great deal for
kodak huge money 90 of all prescriptions
written in the united states are for
generic drugs we have approved more
generic drugs than any other
administration by far
generic drugs can be just as good as the
brand names
but cost much less it's fujifilm brand
plasma
active pharmaceutical ingredients needed
to make these drugs
they're currently manufactured in
america more than 50 percent
however are made in india and china
and you'll be seeing a lot of things
have happened it's been happening
but it's happening at a more rapid pace
right now
with this new agreement my
administration is using the defense
production act to provide a
765 million dollar loan
to support the launch of kodak
pharmaceuticals
it's a great name when you think of it
such a great name was one of the great
brands in the world
then people went digital and kodak
didn't follow
but now under very extraordinary
leadership they are following
and they're doing something that's a
different field and it's a field that
they've really hired some of the best
people in the world he understands
nothing about taking care of that
company and watching that company
watching over it
but it's a breakthrough in bringing
pharmaceutical manufacturing back to the
united states
under this contract our 33rd use of the
defense production act remember when you
were saying i didn't use it enough i
didn't use it enough
and now you've heard that 33rd use we
don't talk about it all the time we used
it and we used it as a
little bit of a threat frankly with
certain companies that weren't doing as
we were asking them to do and it came
through as both a threat and a usage but
this is a 33rd use of the defense
production act
kodak will now produce generic active
pharmaceutical ingredients
which is a big deal using advanced
manufacturing techniques kodak will also
make
the key starting materials that are the
building blocks for many drugs
in a manner that is both cost
competitive and environmentally safe
will be competitive with almost all
countries and soon with all countries
once this new division is fully
operational in addition to all of the
other plants that
we've opened with other companies
throughout the united states recently
it will produce as much as 25 of all
active ingredients needed to make
generic drugs in the usa it's a big
number
25 percent this agreement will
directly create 360 new jobs at kodak's
factory in rochester that's just in the
initial phase
and in minneapolis a place i have gotten
to know very well and it's a great place
and i'm very happy that we're able to
help them with the problems that they've
had
recently the national guard i want to
thank the national guard
oh boy both state and beyond i want to
thank them for the
incredible job they went in and they did
some beautiful job they
cleaned it up you didn't hear about the
problems anymore delusional
and indirectly i want to create we
created thousands more jobs all across
our
pharmaceutical supply chains we have
speaking of jobs just a quick update
yesterday trump said that he saved tens
of millions of energy jobs i was able to
confirm after the stream
there are only six million energy jobs
in the entire country
so how trump saved tens of millions is
beyond me for their tremendous work to
make
this deal possible today's action is our
latest step to build the greatest
medical arsenal in history we'll be able
to do that
through the defense production act and
other authorities we have
invested more than three billion dollars
in our nation's industrial base
we've contracted with companies such as
ford general motors phillips and general
electric to produce more than
200 000 ventilators by the end of this
year
nearly seven times more than we would
ever do in a typical year
we've contracted with honeywell 3m
o m helyart moldex and lydal
light to increase u.s production of n95
masks and
we've brought it from less than 40
million a month to over a hundred
million a month
by august and we'll have 160 million
in a very short while 160 million a
month
that's many times what we used to do if
you go back two years ago
many many times we're increasing
domestic production of gloves
by one thousand percent what about one
thousand percent
we will be manufacturing 450 million
gloves
annually by next year we're finalizing
contracts with our textile industry to
make gowns in america with
american fabric which makes a lot of our
businesses happy that produce the fabric
we have 13 million reusable gowns in the
stockpile and we'll continue to grow
that number to 72
million this fall which is a rapid
escalation indeed
we made major investments in new rapid
point-of-care tests
so we have there's nothing like the
rapid point
where you get your answer in five
minutes to 15 minutes to maybe 20 25
minutes at the max
ideally the right answer if you're trump
at about a 50
level and we're bringing it up very
substantially from there we're growing
domestic production from less than 250
000 test kits per month
in may to 8 million test kits per month
there is nothing like this that has ever
taken place
anywhere in the world or close through
our partnership with puritan
manufacturing in the state of maine
great state
we've increased production of test swabs
from 30 million
per month in june to 56 million per
month now i see you remember i went to
maine i went to the
plant where they do this it was
incredible it's a great experience
and we'll produce over 100 million swabs
per month by january
we've dramatically ramped up production
of materials needed for a vaccine
and earned track to rapidly produce 100
million doses as soon as
a vaccine is approved which could be
very very soon
and 500 million doses shortly thereafter
so we'll have
500 million doses and logistically we're
using our military our great military
a group of people their whole life is
based around logistics and
bringing things to and from locations
and they'll be able to take care of this
locationally and bringing it
where it has to go very very quickly
they're all mobilized it's been fully
set up
a very very talented general is in
charge and
when we have that vaccine it will be
discharged and taken care of it'll be
a very very rapid process all over the
country
and perhaps we'll be supplying a lot of
the vaccine
to other parts of the world like we do
with ventilators and other things that
we
all of a sudden have become very good at
making when the china virus struck our
nation we mobilize the entire government
and the private sector to acquire source
and deliver
life-saving supplies hhs
fema and the private sector combined
have coordinated the delivery of more
than 196 million
n95 respirators 815 million
surgical masks 20 million gloves so of
course this is a distraction from the
fact that most countries
dealt with this months ago in a way that
has gotten the hospitals mostly empty
trump still to everything's like it's
five months ago right we needed the ppe
five months ago
obviously we still need it unfortunately
but the focus now shouldn't be on look
at what you've been able to get
in five months it should be look at how
we have almost no cases of course that's
not the case another thousand people
died today
especially if they have a medical
difficulty a medical problem in
particular heart
or diabetes which provided a total of
1.2 million pairs of protective eyewear
14 million mask
mask 66 million pairs of gloves and
13 million gowns we have replenished the
long neglected he's just ran i mean it's
like he's already given us five
different sets of numbers about gowns
and gloves
it's of no meaning whatsoever asks today
the stockpile has over
50 million n95 masks and we'll be
doubling that in a very short period of
time and then doubling that number
we've shipped more than 14 000
ventilators to areas of need across the
country and we've
more than 75 000 available to deploy
not a single american who has needed a
ventilator
has been denied a ventilator and if you
remember
early on when we were first hit with the
virus
uh ventilators were very hard to come by
and now we're the largest maker anywhere
in the world by far and
not only are we fully supplied in stock
but we're helping other nations because
ventilators are hard to build and hard
to get
this is just the beginning in the coming
months we will continue the largest
onshoring campaign in american history
we will bring back our jobs and we will
make america the world's premier medical
manufacturer and supplier that's what's
happening already it's been happening
now for quite some time by the way when
trump says
50 million gloves do you assume he means
25 million pairs or 50 million pairs
when he says 50 million gloves do you
understand what i'm saying
but we are watching very carefully
california arizona texas
and most of florida that's uh starting
to head down in the right direction
right i think you'll see it rapidly head
down very soon but
if you look california arizona texas and
for the most part most of florida
starting to head down in the wake of the
recent mass gatherings americans have
witnessed in the
streets of portland and seattle we are
also tracking a significant rise in
cases in both metropolitan that's the
trick
it's 50 million gloves but they're all
left-handed gloves that's a real problem
as you know i've done a excellent job of
watching over
portland and watching our courthouse
where they wanted to burn it down
they're
anarchists nothing short of anarchists
agitators
authoritarians and we have protected it
very powerfully
and if we didn't go there i will tell
you you wouldn't have a courthouse you'd
have a
you'd have a billion dollar burned out
building
we're also working aggressively to
combat the virus in native american and
alaska native communities
under the cares act we provided eight
billion dollars to address the
coronavirus in
tribal communities and we've worked very
hard with tribal communities they're
very
vulnerable to this horrible plague i'm
sure he cares about it's the largest
investment in
indian country in u.s history there's
never been an investment that big in
indian country
we need every american to help protect
our fellow citizens and prevent the
spread of the disease
it's critical that younger americans
remember that even though they are at
lower risk and in fact
some are in some age groups are at
extraordinarily low risk
themselves they can unknowingly spread
the virus to others
who are at higher risk i ask all
americans regardless of background or
age to practice social distancing
which people have gotten very used to
but we have to keep doing it remain
vigilant about hygiene
avoid indoor gatherings and
large gatherings but especially indoor
especially
where you have crowd i'm gonna just try
the other stream because the audience
our fellow citizens and prevent the
spread of the disease
it's critical that younger americans
remember that even though they are at
lower risk and in fact
some are in some age groups are at
extraordinary low risk
this is better themselves they can
unknowingly spread the virus to others
who are at higher risk maybe not i ask
all americans regardless of background
or age to practice social distancing
which
people have gotten very used to but we
have to keep doing it
remain vigilant about hygiene avoid
indoor
gatherings and large gatherings but
especially indoor
especially where you have crowded bars
and
that you wear a mask whenever
appropriate
through the genius of our scientists the
devotion of our doctors the skill of our
workers and the dedication of our people
we will achieve victory over the virus
and emerge stronger than ever before
we're looking at a very powerful year
next year economically
hopefully the job numbers are looking
outstanding to put it mildly set records
the numbers on retail retail sales
came in two weeks ago at the highest
number in the history of our country so
we look like we're heading into the
client very good economic times that
means
jobs that means stock market stock
market is already doing very well it's
getting to a point very close to where
it was
when we had this uh when we were hit
with the
the plague so i just want to thank
everybody for being here
question uh steve please go ahead can
you clarify
your acceptance speech for the
republican nomination are you physically
going to be in charlotte or
will you give the speech here somewhere
else we'll be doing a speech
on thursday the main speech the primary
speech
charlotte they will be doing uh
nominating on monday that's a different
that's a different uh period a different
thing happening but they'll be doing
nominations
on monday uh i speak on
thursday okay from where are you going
to charlotte
we'll go we'll be announcing it soon oh
yeah you could be going to charlotte
anybody have any ideas
we'll be announcing it very soon
mr president um the negotiations are
ongoing right now
for the next relief measures republicans
senate republicans have put forth their
plan
do you support what senate republicans
have put forward and are there certain
aspects that they have put forward that
you don't support
yeah there are actually and we'll be
talking about it there are
you know also things that i very much
support um
but we'll be negotiating it's sort of
semi-irrelevant because the democrats
come
with their needs and asks and the
republicans go with theirs
so we'll be discussing it with mitch and
all of the other people involved kevin's
been very active as you know
all of the people involved steve
mnuchin's done a great job
keeps everybody together both democrat
and republican
right and we'll see we want to do what's
best for the people i want to do what's
best for the people
i want to do what's best for the economy
because that means jobs and lots of good
things all right
what do you mean what senate republicans
mr president of two questions quickly uh
first can you clarify your position
on the efficacy of hydroxychloroquine
after
you've retweeted a video uh making
claims
that it is the it's
recommendations of many other peoples
and people including doctors
many doctors think it is extremely
successful
the hydroxychloroquine uh coupled with
the zinc
and perhaps the zithromycin
but many doctors think it's extremely
good
and some people don't some people i
think it's become very political
what do clinical trials i happen to
believe in it i would take it as you
know i took it for a 14-day period
and i mean it was 14. i'm here
uh i happen to think it's uh it works in
the early stages
i think frontline medical people believe
that too some many
and so we'll take a look at it but the
one thing we know it's been out for a
long time that particular
formula and that's what essentially what
it is the pill so is arsenic does it
mean
malaria lupus and other things uh it uh
it's safe it doesn't cause problems
i had no problem i had absolutely no
problem felt no different
didn't feel good bad or indifferent and
i tested as you know it didn't
it didn't get me and it's not going to
hopefully hurt anybody so we know from
that stanford
because it's been so many years from a
safety standpoint it's safe
can you imagine people like based on
what i've read i've read a lot
about what he reads all the time yeah
that's political i happen to think that
it has an impact especially at the
early years there were some very good
tests at ford and
the doctor from yale came up with a very
very strong
testament to it there was a group of
doctors yesterday a large group that
were put on the internet and for some
reason the internet wanted someone
explaining science to him
and uh took them off i guess twitter
took them off and
i think facebook took them off i don't
know why i think they're very respected
doctors
most fake news there was a woman who was
spectacular in her statements about it
that she's had tremendous success with
it and they took her
they took her voice off i don't know why
they took her off but they took her off
maybe they had a good reason maybe they
didn't i don't know
i can only say that from my standpoint
uh
and based on a lot of reading and a lot
of knowledge about it
i think it could have a very positive
impact
in the early stages and i don't think
you lose anything by doing it
other than politically uh it doesn't
seem to be too popular you know why
because i recommend it when i recommend
something
they like to say don't use it john
please on that note mr president last
night in tweets that were deleted by
twitter
you said that dr fauci misled the
country about hydroxychloroquine
no not at all i think i don't even know
what his stance is on it
but then why didn't he was just you know
he was at the white house
he was at the task force meeting a
little while ago he had a very good
relationship with dr fauci you know it's
sort of interesting we've listened to dr
fauci i haven't always agreed with him
and that's i think pretty standard
that's okay
uh he did not want us to ban our
this this put up the ban to china when
china was heavily infected very badly
wuhan
he didn't want to do that and i did and
other things and he told me i was right
and he told me i saved
tens of thousands of lives which was
generous but it's
you know i think it's fact then i banned
i did the ban on europe
but i get along with him very well and i
agree with a lot of what he said
uh so you know it's interesting uh
he's got a very good approval rating and
i like that i it's good
no he's jealous he's working for this
administration he's working with us
john we we could have gotten other
people we could have
gotten somebody else it didn't have to
be dr fauci he's working with our
administration and for the most part
we've done pretty much what he and
others dr burks and others who are
terrific wow
recommended my god and he's got this
high approval rating so
why don't i have a high approval rating
with that that's exactly the
administration
with respect to the virus we should have
a very good what bothers him
what we've done we're just reading off
about the masks and the gowns and the
ventilations why don't i have it
numbers that nobody's seen and the
testing of 55
million tests we tested more than
anybody in the world i have a graph that
i'd love to show you i'm
perhaps you've seen it where we're up
here and the rest of the world is down
at 11. now he's just flying again
but it's just a tiny fraction in terms
of testing
so it sort of is curious a man works for
us with us very closely dr fauci and dr
burks also highly
thought of high approval i don't know
yet they're highly thought of but nobody
likes me
it can only be my personality that's all
go ahead can i just ask you
also uh dhs announced today that it is
going to undertake a thorough review of
the daca program to decide whether to
continue it and if not
how to dispense if you had mentioned uh
after the supreme court
uh ruling about daca that you were
thinking about a path to citizenship
for daca recipients are you still
thinking we're going to work with a lot
of people on daca and we're also working
on an immigration bill a merit-based
system which is what i've wanted for a
long time
that decision was an interesting
decision because it gave the president
as a president more power than many
people thought the president had so the
president
is now which happens to be me in a
position where i can do
an immigration bill and a health care
bill and some other bills and you've
seen some of them come along
we're going to do tremendous if we just
signed it
three days ago we're doing tremendous
prescription drug price
reductions tremendous it could be over
50 percent
whether it's favored nations clauses or
anything else i mean it's tremendous
numbers we're talking about
you know you go to some countries and
they'll sell like a pill
for 10 cents and in the united states it
costs
two dollars and it's the same basic
factory it's the same everything the
united states bears the cost of all of
these low prices that you see all over
the world where people go to canada
to buy a prescription drug from the
united states
not going to happen with me it's not
going to happen with me so john i think
one of the exciting things he's got very
little coverage and that's okay but the
people understand it
uh i think we will be reducing
prescription drug prices by
massive amounts numbers that have never
been done before
other thing in 51 years we got as you
know last year
drug prices came down first time in 51
years
that they came down now with what i
signed last week
i think that drug prices can come down
uh
by numbers like 50 and even greater in
certain instances
where i originally started are you still
considering a path to citizenship for
current doctors
we are going to make daca happy and the
daca people and representatives happy
and we're also going to end up with a
fantastic
merit-based immigration system please
yeah
um uh on the drug pricing you had said
that pharmaceutical representatives
would be here today for a meeting to
talk about bringing drug prices down
yeah that meeting was cancelled why i
didn't know a meeting was canceled oh a
meeting with the
drug there would be a meeting today with
drug companies
uh well i said there would be a meeting
yeah of meeting sometime this week yeah
they want to meet i mean i don't know
that it was canceled they wanted me
uh i thought the meeting was actually
scheduled for tomorrow
yeah i thought i thought the meeting was
scheduled tomorrow sorry about the dates
but you know
i see how upset you are by it go ahead
please bloomberg
bloomberg mr bloomberg you look like mr
bloomberg go ahead
thank you mr president would you support
the temporary extension of
supplemental unemployment aid if uh the
deal that they're hashing out in
congress isn't completed by the end of
this week we'll do something
we're gonna take care of the people yeah
it's a good question we're gonna take
care of the people
the woman that you said was a great
doctor in that video that you retweeted
last night said that masks don't work
and there is a cure for covid19
both of which health experts say is not
true she's also made videos saying that
doctors make medicine using dna from
aliens and that they're trying to create
a vaccine to make you immune from
becoming religious
maybe it's the same maybe it's not but i
i can't i can tell you this no it's the
same person she was
on air along with many other doctors
they were big fans of
hydroxy chloroquine and i thought she
was very impressive
in the sense that from where she came i
don't know which country she comes from
but she said that she's had tremendous
success with hundreds of different
patients
and i thought her voice was an important
voice but i know nothing about her
thank you very much everybody caitlyn
collins too prepared he's not going to
allow it to continue if she's going to
get the talk yeah it's just too
too i mean you know accurately brings up
that this woman has
who's he's quoting retweeting on
hydroxychloroquine
also talked about aliens and um he
uh just abruptly ends nasty nasty nasty
stuff there folks
so i guess we know what's on the show
tomorrow at least uh
partially um so listen from the
standpoint of subscribers
we hit 900 000 we're actually over it
i don't know why socialblade hasn't
updated yet
even though it says it updates every
second maybe it only updates every 10
minutes or something
but we did it it's anti-climactic in
that the number hasn't changed
i'll refresh uh but we did it we are at
900 000 subscribers it would be great if
we actually could show it to you but
i don't know something something very
weird is going on um
but thank you thank you to everybody who
who helped us to
uh get there and onward and upward to
1 million on youtube and 50 000 on
twitch listen we've only been on twitch
for like nine months but we're working
on that as well
but a bizarre bizarre event here
um and i'm going to be processing
all of the very tr not high level ideas
but
very very low level ideas i'm gonna have
to be processing that
um for a while for a while because it
was so crazy so thanks for joining me
please on the way out if you're watching
on twitch hit that follow button it's
free it's a free button
and if you're watching on youtube please
do hit that subscribe button we are the
the
race is officially on to 1 million
subscribers
i want to do it before election day um
we're on track for january 6th so we
would miss
election day by a couple of months but
it's conceivably possible all right so
we're the race to a million is on and
i'll see you guys very soon
you